somebody did a video the other day from
portland oregon of one of these parks
where they've really done their best
you know the protesters and it's just it
really does look like the apocalyptic
wasteland they deserved just covered in
and just people just lying zonked out
on whatever illegal or legal drugs
they've been able to get and
everyone just looks like they've pissed
themselves and they've
taken all the statues are down of course
the whole place is covered in plinths
beautiful plinths everywhere uh no but
and all the plinths are covered in blm
graffiti and the state and police of
this and that's what these people
inherit
and they deserve to inherit it a urine
stenched
graffitied wasteland in which just
zombies lie around until they die
i'm joined by douglas murray douglas
welcome to the show
great to be with you again it's been uh
what two
a year probably yeah one year one year
since we spoke and it feels you've done
your ceiling
i've done my ceiling so all of the
people on the internet that were
complaining and saying
was that mold on the ceiling it wasn't
it was candle soot i went through a
period where i loved yankee candles for
a while
but we're out the other side but yeah it
was only a year ago which feels like
75 years ago doesn't it just
doesn't adjust uh we're both looking
okay despite that i'd like to think
i hope so i mean i've lost an achilles
but um that's that's really the only
thing that's gone wrong
so at the end of 2019 when the madness
of crowds came out
i asked you what chapters you could have
added which you omitted
and you said mental health and green
what's your answer in 2020
i think i'd stay with that um
green in particular has been really
doing well
in the lunatic olympics um
they they've they've got a whole new
wardrobe of lunacy
uh they've got new makeup that shows
they're mad
they actually dress to say i'm mad um
so i i do feel still
a bit annoyed that i never did the green
chapter but as i say there's
there's an awful lot of material in
those guys and girls
um i would observe simply though that
since we last spoke everything i write
about in the manners of crowds
everything i do put in on gay on
women on race and on trans has just
which you know i could see coming it was
why i was trying to warn people about it
and uh but goodness particularly in the
last few months
so much more than i ever feared could
happen this fast
do you feel vindicated that you got it
right or sad that it occurred as you
prophesized
do you know i don't like vindication all
that much
you should try it sometime yeah i mean
it's always nice when people point it
out
but uh it actually doesn't feel that
great that because
if you say look here's this terrible
thing that's coming towards you
and then it happens anyway you know you
feel like maybe you didn't warn well
enough
or you didn't warn you know clearly
enough or something like that but
i might be over doing what you can
achieve in in warning but you know i i
do feel that those of us and there are
a number of us who said look dig down
into these identity traits
things and you won't heal society you'll
make
it more discombobulated and eventually
you'll make it more divided
and you're not going to solve it you're
going to make it worse you know a number
of us said that but
you know too many people thought no
we love the sound of the apocalypse
you're talking about let's get there
faster let's take the fast route
yeah you're right they got first class
they went vip upgrade yeah they got the
trolley
service as well um what have we learned
from jk rowling
this year wow
well um who ever thought
that the creator of harry potter would
become goebbels
uh i mean the most unforgivable
cancelled person it's extraordinary i
never thought that the harry potter or i
mean i never thought that the people who
are great fans of jk rowling would
would turn on her this much
the only thing i i've ever seen that i
can think of that it reminds me of was
i once saw some footage from trafalgar
square of some young girls who had
stayed out all night
waiting for leonardo dicaprio to come
for the
premiere of a movie and it was raining
and he didn't
stay very long to greet them because it
was raining and i remember
this footage of him i hate him
and they'd turned from
so devoted so devoted
they had camped out and arranged their
lives around
the possibility of a glimpse and got to
i hate him he's the nastiest man in the
world in no time
and that seems to be what's happening
with jk rowling um now of course not
with all her fans i don't
i don't over emphasize it but you know
there is a portion of people who believe
that the harry potter woman who they
relied on all the time when they were
growing up and who gave them
all this you know great time uh has
become
a nazi when they weren't looking and
i don't i should stress i don't think
she has
but there's a lot to learn firstly in
the
dementing tones of the time second in
the way in which
public figures can just be made
versions of them that have no
resemblance to what they are become
you know played out there in the public
sphere
and then you get the very interesting
other lessons i i don't like this term
cancel
culture i think it's sort of uh it's
already stale and it's not quite
accurate because
you know jk running hasn't been
cancelled or anything like that you know
there's a bunch of very insane people
who
think that the ichabog is too difficult
for them
to cope with in this life and by the way
i mean
because that's that was the attempt the
war of the attempted walk out at her
publishers hashed
was was not uh because they didn't
the the the i think 150 or so people
mainly young
at hachette who said they couldn't work
on the latest jk rowling book and didn't
want to be in the same
places they weren't publishing jk
rowling's big
book of trans it wasn't
chicks with dicks by j.k rowling
dumbledore and harry have an x-rated
adventure it wasn't that
no it wasn't that it was a new
children's book to be called the ichabog
and if you are an adult in the world
and you can't be in the proximity of a
children's book called the ichabog
it's possible this world isn't going to
be able to be arranged around you
anymore
you know it's it's that's that's that's
a bad
place to be and so
jk rowling's story has lots of things to
tell us but one of them is
what can be done by one person just one
person
second thing is we are learning lessons
about who can be counseled who cannot
and the fact
that clearly it matters
that she makes money and that she has
money
now that's not all a good sign because
it means that those of us who aren't
multi-zillionaires
are still vulnerable and i wouldn't like
to be in a position where only the very
rich can survive
attempted cancellation um
[Music]
but it shows that one person with a
voice
and with some guts she certainly has
that can say look
i'm not persecuting anyone i'm just
telling you
i'm not going along with the following
crazy thing you made up yesterday
and i admire her for doing that you know
she had no she didn't have to get into
any of this
she could quite easily have you know
continued buying you know
harry potter castle sized houses and
living very happy
most people most people will be very
happy to have a quiet life
and um and enjoy their their their their
loot
uh but she uh she she's done this and i
have all
all respect for her for doing so it's
the sort of thing
her legacy in whatever form that will be
i'm sure that she is going to be
remembered you know harry potter is one
of the most
popular children series ever and and
really sort of was a pivot as well with
regards to
um children's literature i think that
was adult friendly as well you know like
you had kids
they even did special adult um cover
versions yes i know that was less less
embarrassed reading
i thought very poorly of the adult i
read the children's editions i thought
very poorly of the adults who who
thought they were fooling everyone by
reading
still harry potter yeah um but yeah and
you're right she could have just
quietly allowed that legacy to roll
forward without doing anything to
potentially upset the balance but she
decided not to
yeah yeah and i i just think that we
need to reflect more on when things go
well you know you hear an awful lot
about you know when things are going
badly
this has gone very well you know um
there was a fear around the time of the
jk writing thing
that maybe even making money for a
company didn't protect you
you know that look at netflix netflix
has been willing
to to take financial hits in order to do
worse
programs so long as they're in the right
political realm um
i worried in the publishing industry
that would be the case with jk rowling
but but
but fortunately not um
fortunately it's still you know success
still speaks and i'm i'm
delighted by the people by the way i
don't have been snotty about this but
some of the people who resigned there
were some people who resigned from her
literary agency
because her the literary agent was now
representing an anti-trans
person and i just it was
one of the funniest reads of the year
reading
the authors who'd resigned from jk
rowling's literary agency i
i can tell you her literary agent isn't
any poorer
i'll just i'll put it at its most
diplomatic the literary agents praying
to the gods thanking them that they
finally rid themselves of some
non-selling authors yeah yeah so um
so no but it's been it's been a very
it's been a very good thing because i
think we might have spoken about this
when we last spoke but
you know i i've always said that uh
cowardice is catching
and when a society sort of encourages
people to be sort of cowardly and meek
and shut up and all that sort of thing
and if the public figures all do that
then other people do it
but the reverse is also true and if you
know mainstream and totally responsible
and respected figures like jk rowling
uh do do this and fantastic more
more more men and women will say what
they think
and they won't go along with stuff just
because they're told they have to
particularly it's mad stuff that was
just made up yesterday
so you said cancel culture is a term
that you're not
super happy with what is the
cancellation sphere that
that's out there in the world at the
moment well the clear one that does
exist
is the attempt to find people whose
employment
is vulnerable to mob stampeding
so you know somebody says something on
twitter for instance
uh in support of somebody that twitter
doesn't like
and the twitter then finds where they
work
and uh you know lobbies their boss until
they're sacked something that that's
that's
that's the aim and there's lots of sort
of versions of that
um lobby a company uh pretend that you
know
the company's to lose masses of money
because it's just destroyed its market
you know capability because everyone's
unhappy with it
um that stuff does go on
um but you're not happy with that being
called cancel culture well no no
it's not that i what i'm what i'm
worried about is that we get stuck on
it um because
i believe it's much more important to
focus on what
is winning and what winning looks like
and you know there is a certain you
notice this in american journalism a bit
more than you do here there was a bit of
oh i was so nearly canceled oh i was
cancelled
there's a sort of certain you know
you always have it in writing because
writers are a very self-obsessed bunch
and tend to think of themselves as being
brave i mean you know mark stein made a
famous quip years ago you know like
writers are forever giving each other
awards for bravery and you know
you don't all of the professions where
they're you know like you've got to run
into burning buildings and save people
there's like they don't spend all their
time talking about bravery awards you
know
but but writers are very big on bravery
and writers like
quite a lot of writers like the idea
that they're sort of you know edgy and
and all that sort of thing and so they
say the idea of being cancelled a little
bit you know
for them i don't really care about that
stuff i i care about people saying what
they
think and i'm really
i really think that people should not
pay so much attention to a
very very rarefied and demented minority
of people
and i don't think we should give these
people the right to dictate the cultural
weather in
any way in any way
why should a small demented group of
people
who believe that the big bearded man
with a penis is a woman if he says he is
that they should dictate the cultural
weather across the country
and make major authors have to fear for
their careers
and make all politicians become
gibbering wrecks
when the subject comes up why should
that be the case
why can't we just have discussions out
in a reasonable fashion
and you know advance your case the best
of your capability but you don't do that
i think we've given in issue after issue
very deranged
minorities minorities of minorities
the right to basically dictate the
weather and and we don't need to
because on any estimation on any
estimation
you know most of those people are not
doing that well
you know the authors who are the
anti-rolling people are not doing as
well as her
so why not you know why not say actually
the person the point about this is is to
say
the person in your life you should want
to be is jk rowling not just because you
should want to be rich but because you
should want to be in a position in your
life where you can tell the truth
that should be the position you aim for
and i'm worried that all of this sort of
actually encourages people to say
the position i would like to sort of
hold in my life will be the one where
nobody notices me and nobody comes for
me and i sort of get away with it and
then die
how vanilla can i spend the remainder of
my life i'd like to be
somewhere in between the color eggplant
and beige
absolutely on the on the great color
chart of humanity
human experience and that's but that's
what that's what that's what they're
doing and i just
i think we should encourage people not
not to play that game
it's hard right if you've hit on
something there that
people like yourself or sam harris or jk
rowling
by virtue of uh success or financial
backing or
a level of independence with regards to
your platform or whatever it might be
have taken great got in great lengths uh
to make yourself
uncounselable but not everyone has that
luxury sure no no i don't i don't
underestimate it at all
um i just my experience in life is that
i've always said what i
think and uh it's worked well not doing
you that's that's the thing i said
before our first podcast like
how do we get through all of these
topics without stepping on a landmine
and you increasingly just sort of do a a
ballerina dance through this land yeah
back and forth everything i'd like to
think it's slightly more butch than that
but but i agree it's something like
somewhere in that yeah yeah a new af
like leaps around like
that that's what you're that that was
the image that was in your mind
i've got this image of you in a pink
tutu that's just dancing
through a minefield but that's we're too
close here now i'm just
thrilled that the image is in your mind
[Laughter]
but but no i mean i uh yeah that's my
experience
um it is not to say that it's completely
easy i mean you know you
you have to do your work and you have to
work hard you have to you know
weigh your words and you speak them as
when you write them but you you know any
normal person would anyway
and um but yeah i i i just i think we've
got to change the um
you know there's this thing that's gone
on in our era in general
i think it's came out last time that
that we've moved from the heroic
mood in the society to the victim mood
you know we've moved in general from the
who is the person who's been most heroic
in their lives to the sort of
celebration of whoever's
can say they've been the most victimized
and this is all a little bit of that
it's a little offshoot of it
and i'm not really that interested in
victimhood
not because i'm um hard-hearted or
anything like that it's just that
my observation of life is that we can
all of us
whinge endlessly if we want to about our
lot
because human experience is
extraordinary in lots of ways and will
always include an awful lot of mundanity
and pain and grief
and much much more so
we could all do it um
i'm just not sure that our society
should encourage it as much as it does
i think you're right there's an
interesting translation
uh change that came across recently um
the buddha said
life is suffering but the word of
suffering is duca
duka and as with all ancient
translations it's a nearest closest
term that they try to find right and
suffering was one of the translations
but there's some scholars that can test
that it's not suffering it's
unsatisfactoriness life is
unsatisfactoriness
and if you spend a lot of time in
evolutionary psychology you realize
that that unsatisfactoriness is fitness
enhancing if you were yes
absolutely fully actualized upon killing
your first bison you'd never kill
another bison
upon having sex the first time you'd
never have sex again
exactly i i do know people like that
but the come on
no you're right look the
unsatisfactionist is of course wanting
to do better wanting to do more
um a lot of people find this
uh with the accretion of wealth uh never
get enough of it
um it's not not the best way to do it uh
but
it it's it's one thing yes and
unsatisfiedness
is isn't an entirely bad thing um
it's an enormous drive for a lot of
people
um it's it's obviously one of the things
behind ambition
and and yes i i think there's a there's
there's an awful lot of things going on
in our age but we we should
try to identify the things that we are
erroneously holding up
as good and i do think i do think that
holding up victimhood is
as not just good but meaning that you
especially deserve a platform or a
microphone
has turned out to be a an unhelpful
way to start a new generation off in
this world it's a jordan petersonism
right where he talks about the fact that
uh a rabbit isn't inherently good
because it's unable to commit evil
it's the enacting your shadow fully
fully internalizing your shadow from the
jungian perspective
um and the same with that like you you
very correct there is no bravery
in avoiding courageous challenges
right um and and one of the things uh
again we touched on this last met but
one of the things i'm particularly
worried about in this era is what's
happening to men
in all of this because men seem to me
the primary people at the moment who
have been persuaded
to lessen their capabilities lessen
the things they could achieve and sort
of
just find a way to get through this
strange
period that we're in and and it's it's
not healthy it's not healthy for men
it's not healthy for women
um it makes very unhappy men and it
makes
they unhappy women because women don't
want those men
what are your thoughts on looting as a
method of hastening change
i'm mainly against it um
are you ever for it no not i can think
of
uh you're referring i assume among other
things to the book that's just been
published in america
in defense of looting 2016 that came out
you know
did it really gosh that was actually
really really interesting
so the it's had its moment now that book
hasn't it
she is so much more insightful than you
her ability to see what's going on in
the future
is that much greater than yours yeah and
so vikki osterweil for anyone who
doesn't know what it is i've got a
little
a little breakdown here and then i'll
get your opinions on it um
so npr summarizes the book as an
argument that quote
looting is a powerful tool to bring
about real lasting change in society end
quote
osterwile's argument is simple the
so-called united states was founded in
quote cis hetero patriarchal
racial capitalist violence that violence
produced our current system particularly
its property relations and
looting is a remedy for that sickness
looting rejects the legitimacy of
ownership rights
and property the moral injunction to
work for a living in the justice of law
and order
ownership of things not just people is
innately structurally white supremacist
looting is good she says because it
exposes a deep truth about the great
american confidence game which is that
without
quote without police and without state
oppression we can have things for free
she came to this conclusion six years
ago
and in her book which is written in love
and solidarity with loot is the world
over
well the obvious question is where does
she live
[Laughter]
the only thing you need to know do you
know that at the front of the book
they have the classic um this is
copyrighted by whatever publishing
i know because a colleague of mine a
spectator wrote to her publishers the
other day
saying we are publishing our own edition
of this
uh looting her book you were just
looting her book
and the publishers didn't seem to be up
for that you'd be amazed to hear
well i mean i just said look if you see
it in the bookshop take it it's yours
all properties theft why not
turns out actually nobody wants to steal
her book certainly not if it's filled
with stuff like you just read um
these people i mean they're so
reprehensible on so many levels i mean
first of all by the way
um how ignorant can somebody be
i mean how ignorant do you have to be to
make that claim about the foundation of
american society
and i suspect like a number of authors
of the american far left she's never
been
anywhere else in the world in her life i
just strongly suspect that
um if if she can send me photos of
herself in sub-saharan africa
north africa across a lot of the middle
east and the far east and things i i
could be persuaded
but i would suspect that she's been
brought up in america hasn't traveled
very much further and has simply been
indoctrinated in this now completely
boring and predictable way
where all you need to do is throw out
this same word salad about
heteronormativity and
uh and indigenous people and all this
sort of thing and before you know it
you've got a
not very well selling book that you
can't even get stolen
but the the
do you remember the sargon of akkad
thing that he got really really in
trouble for
where he said i wouldn't even rape you
that was his
thing to the politician i can't remember
the lady's name and that was what got
him in trouble
this is a book so bad you wouldn't even
steal it
it can't be so i mean if anyone can show
me an example of it being stolen but
you know um it's it's also i mean
it's it's it's amazing we're in this era
and that people are
talking and thinking like this i i
simply think it's
she is a product of
capitalism at this particular stage
where um she doesn't know very much she
hasn't been very far
in the world she's not been educated
well
she's not seen anything of the world she
doesn't know anything about life she
doesn't know how life is normally
run and all of that is playing out on
the streets of various american cities
at the moment primarily portland oregon
uh but there are a lot of people in this
strange
position i i have a lot of friends in
america who tell me that this
is very common this sort of thing among
their children and grandchildren they
say that they
they they genuinely think like this uh
woman that
uh that their country is uniquely bad
and these people just don't know
anything they just don't know anything
i don't know anything about history they
don't know anything about geography they
don't know anything about the world
and i'm i'm very uninterested in the
thoughts
of these intensely parochial so-called
internationalists
uh because that's what they are i mean
they just they have never seen
the consequences of their own thought
they they
the idea that you take away the police
and everything will be was it free i
think she said
yeah yeah well you also will get a
massive upsurge in rape
murder disproportionately in minority
communities as well yeah and um and then
what are you going to blame it on
uh maybe the period when we still had
police and there's a lingering there's a
ling
lingering overness that makes people do
that for a time
i mean this is juvenile thinking this is
not juveniles it's wicked
and juvenile thinking um again
i don't think very many people believe
it and i think that this is
there is an argument it's a bleak
argument that people like her simply
have to see this tested
close up at some point did we not see
this with chas chop
was that not a perfect microcosm for
this that you could absolutely
you can have idiocy masquerading as
moral virtue
within a few there are certain there are
certain very very pertinent
the chas chad was a very
uh good example of it there are lots of
individuals who
who demonstrate it do you remember that
big story i think it was in the
new york times when it was still a
newspaper uh which
uh where there was a description of a
couple an american couple again
something like oregon someone else no
that could be another couple this couple
didn't have guns as far as they
they're very anti-gun they were very
pro-peace though
and they feared that the world was
lacking in love and they just needed to
give a bit more love to the world
and you can see how this ends already
can't you uh they decided to go on a
cycling holiday and sort of spread
spread
well something or other and uh then they
ended up just getting
killed by a jihadi cell in like
tajikistan
and they did a blog of their stops in
various places in the far east and the
near east there's cycling i think a lot
of tandem even
and then they just you know one day they
you know it's all
this all the stuff is like we just you
know you think the world just needs more
love and
and more tandem holidays they've got
rose petals they've got a basket of rose
petals in front
yeah and and this this a couple of guys
a couple of jihadis
saw them one day and just you know on
the flute so i couldn't believe their
luck clearly and just
just took them out so
human naivety is very familiar and
one has to be careful not to laugh too
much of the people who express it but
it's a very
it's a very common thing uh to be
totally naive about the nature of the
world
ordinarily you get over it when you're
very young
unfortunately in america in particular
we have a generation of
juveniles who are growing up and still
juvenile
and who actually believe these things
who actually believe that
you know life is really quite
straightforward you know if you just
don't have the police and you say defund
the police and you don't have
don't have the patriarchal
cis-heteronormative state then
then what i mean by the way did you see
somebody did a video the other day from
portland oregon of one of these parks
where they've really done their best you
know
uh uh the protesters and it's just it
really does look like the apocalyptic
wasteland they deserved
just covered in piss and just people
just
lying zonked out on whatever illegal or
legal drugs they've been able to get and
everyone just looks like they've pissed
themselves and they've
taken they've taken i'm not everyone
wearing a trench coat that's what i
imagine
lots of friends they're all wearing
someone else's trench coat yeah and yeah
and and the and they've got all the
statues are down of course the whole
place is covered in plinths
uh beautiful plinths everywhere uh no
but
and all the plinths are covered in blm
graffiti and [ __ ] the state and
police of this and that's what these
people inherit and they deserve to
inherited
a urine stenched graffitied wasteland
in which just zombies lie around until
they die
i really want to just put that as the
trailer that's just
the episode that's you know that
this is what they deserve this is what
they deserve this is the final end point
of yourself
i can't believe that there are actually
adults talking about
this or stuff and the new york times and
the new you know
the npr and things taking these
discussions seriously
we we've done the experiment many times
before in human history of what happens
when you have
a total breakdown of law and order and
it always comes out looking
exactly like portland oregon what does
the silent majority need to stop being
silent mean
yes this is something a very keen people
take into account i'm fed up of hearing
about the silent majority
um i've heard about it all my life i'm
sure you have people say well a silent
majority don't believe that i've always
said but why are they silent
what's the problem and if they're a
majority even more so what
that's it makes no sense to me
um the thing that we've been told in
recent years is
the silent majority only stops being
silent at
elections when it silently votes in ways
that surprise
the rest of the country which it seems
is is kind of
kind of true right yeah the obvious
example is
um brexit vote in 2016 and the trump
vote in 2016.
and uh uh then they said well now we've
heard from the silent majority
and then that silent majority is said to
be totally you know deplorable and
um and it should be you know somehow
expunged in the democratic process
because it doesn't know what it's doing
says the losing minority um
but uh yeah i don't understand
why it should be the case that people
only make themselves heard
at the ballot box once every four years
or something like that
um so what i think is happening is back
to
where we started actually is that a very
small number of
very valuable people are making all of
the weather
uh and i don't see why they should and
the only reason they
they do is because they manage to
intimidate
the majority into going along with
things that we don't have to go along
with
i just i refuse and i think everyone
else should
to go along with any more of the crab i
strongly urge people to stop going along
with the crap now what does that mean
it means for instance if you
work in a company and you are told that
you're going to have a day where you've
all got to think about racism
you either say no or you say
what is it you're trying to make us
learn
and what are you trying to make us
conclude and are you right
in that so i published a little while
ago a
letter had been leaked from the nhs
trust where this nhs trust chief in
birmingham
told everyone working for her what books
to read
and i think that the people working for
her and with her should not just laugh
at her
or say oh my gosh i didn't realize how
racist i am in the nhs trust in
birmingham i had no idea that the nhs
trust in birmingham was the place where
the fourth reich was going to re-emerge
why we must stop it
they don't just do that they say no
no we're not going to spend the rest of
our lives being
told what to read and told what to
think and told what to say and told how
to dance and
everything else no we're not going to do
it
and if if the so-called silent majority
did that then we would be so much
further forward as a society
and what's more we can do it in a
perfectly reasonable way
i i've had experience a lot in recent
weeks i'm sure you have
wanting to have conversations about you
know by the way you always told oh we
just want to have the conversation about
this no you don't you want to lecture
people
but i'd be very happy to have
conversations about colonialism and
slavery and
racism and the existence of racism
throughout history across all races and
i'm very happy to have all those
conversations but actually the people
who say they want those conversations
don't want the conversations they just
want to win
what they want is to wear a unitard
spandex khaki coloured sort of
one piece thing and to tell you that
you're racist and put their paypal
address up on the board that's what they
want to do yeah yeah
they want to be the kim young owner of
anti-racism
and um to tell everyone
uh um what to believe and
uh i don't think that's uh uh i'm not
going along with that
so i i don't think other people should
either i got a
small confession to make both to
yourself into the audience i've been
holding on to this story since we got to
speak so i had uh carl benjamin sagan of
a card on the show
a few months ago and it was slap bang
as chas was happening so we're talking
peak race tensions
right and i've spoken to carl before we
get on really well
episodes are great but for some reason i
had this ambient anxiety throughout the
day
leading up to it and i started talking
to him and i was really nervous i don't
usually get
nervous especially when speaking to
guests for a second time so it's just a
friend
how are you how's this that and the
other sure and um
i found myself being super super it
felt like i was training on eggshells as
i'm talking to him and then upon
listening back even some of the things
that i said i didn't agree with i didn't
agree with myself
and what sort of things so yeah sorry
for instance
um we were talking about should the
faulty towers episode be taken down
what's happening with the little britain
variety released a list of 10
problematic movies which need warnings
and a discussion before and after
watching
and i put this stuff forward to carl and
he gave his thoughts
and i just after that was done i said i
pushed the rhetoric of my compassion too
far i was saying basically
i don't think that anyone should be
offended which isn't true because
in order to communicate you have to risk
being offensive that's the way it works
another jordan peterson-ism
so anyway what i found was that i had
somehow managed to and that
listeners may be able to sense this
within their own lives
i'd become so ignorant to where the goal
posts were
that i wasn't i didn't even know what
sport i was playing anymore
and i feel like this is the end goal
which
a lot of the um smarter people
who are using uh just
justice movements to further a
particular agenda
are hoping to achieve to make the goal
post so fast
that you don't know what's right what's
wrong well it's anything else
and i i was super nervous and that yeah
yeah that's
personally you're completely right and
here here are a couple examples of that
um tony abbott former australian prime
minister
uh was appointed by the uk government as
a trade advisor
the last week in the days leading up to
his appointment
various people led by a number of
left-wing broadcasters and newspapers
claim that tony abbott is a you can do
it homophobe misogynist
granny killer uh they did actually do
that weird
and uh global warming denier that's the
that's the big four isn't it bingo
well no the big the biggest one the
fifth one they actually weren't quite
brave enough to do which was to accuse
him of racism
but they accused him of all the other
stuff and uh he's none of those things
by the way he's none of those things
he's a terrific terrific guy and a
terrific public servant and the former
prime minister of australia for goodness
sake
um so anyway but the point is is that
the day
the day before the appoint the day of
the appointment and the day after it
the guardian had on the front page both
days
the government appoints misogynist
advisor
okay as if that's proven okay it's
proven i mean they put it in quote scare
quotes just to make sure they were
legally a bit
better terrain but that was what they
said now if i was a young woman
or a young man growing up with an
ordinary level of incuriosity
i would look at that or might look at
that and think
that's awful and that's awful the
british government's deliberately
appointing someone who
who hates women now
as it happens the the longer you go on
in life the more you
you you get a sense of things the more
you rise what's [ __ ] in the guardian
and what's real life
but it is easy to see how somebody can
be
given a wrong view of an entire society
once you imbibe little things like that
now that's an easy one let me give you a
harder one
the killing of george floyd
um we are in a very powerless position
on this all of us
because i don't know how much time
you've spent in the us
i spend a bit of okay so like me
they have racial problems that we don't
have here i would submit
every country has racial problems
there's a peculiar and particular one
that has existed in america throughout
history
you could also argue that in the most
militarized country in the world
the most militarized law enforcement it
has a
likelihood of fatal encounters with the
public
that is higher than say in britain
where most of the time the police just
spend the time running away from
protesters
um and um uh
but the point is is that if you didn't
know america that well i'm giving here
the the
nicest best analysis of something that's
going on at the moment that i can do
if you didn't know america very well you
didn't know very many americans and you
read
that this white cop had been allowed
to kill a black man on camera for eight
minutes
and that that was okay is it what
and that this happened a lot
you would join black lives matter
absolutely you would want to join
something that said that's not
on that's not right
and the problem is there are these
moments by the way black lives matter
was just primed for a
george floyd-like event and um
and lots of reasons to do with lockdown
i think the sort of the world was in a
way
but what i think happens in those
moments is
it's very hard for people to get a
correct sense of exactly what is going
on so
maybe the police in america do kill
black people
with impunity is a thought that crosses
your mind
maybe america is a racist state maybe
the british police are like that maybe
britain's like that maybe we're all
racist maybe there's such a thing as
white supremacy and it's everywhere and
so on and so forth and it all starts
from that first
inaccurate estimation of what's going on
so the killer of george floyd is in
custody
awaiting trial on charge of murder
he literally has no defenders in the
public sphere
he has a lawyer but nobody says i think
he did great
so what is this utilization of this one
appalling incident and it's widening out
not just to encompass say all police in
the minnesota area
or all police in that state all police
in america
every white person every white person on
the planet no
no you don't get to do that no way
but in that moment you see certain
very very bad actors advancing
because they feel they've got an
advantage and that is the moment when
people become
worried because it's hard to interpret
exactly what the situation is
and bad actors deliberately pump lies
into the system
they say yes you can do this in america
because black lives aren't worth
anything
that we there were there was a very
moving press conference with some of the
police in new york but the police she
was just standing with his colleagues
saying
people are getting away with saying
things like
one activist said i don't even know if
we don't know if we're black if our
children will return from school
or whether they'll just be shot by the
police and this policeman was saying
that isn't the case in environmental
yeah it's not the case but again if you
don't know the country very well or if
you do and you have a certain
understanding of it or a
misunderstanding of it or if you're a
long way away
it's possible to imbibe those ideas
and so that's why i say that one of the
deranging things in our time
is that a very significant number of
people particularly young people
have been given or have given themselves
an erroneous interpretation of the
society they're in
and that's how you end up with the
lunatic you know writing
a book about the in defense of looting
and that's how you end up with people on
the streets of portland running around
looking for nazis and not being able to
find them and so smashing in some old
woman's face
now that's that's how you get there and
reasonable people of any political
direction just have to be able to say no
we're not going along you know you
what it is actually it's like the roman
legion thing that the people in portland
sort of tried to do
they use terrible and
very freakish events to push forward
and behind them is a whole legion of
hell
that is the purpose that is what blm and
others have been doing
and it has to be said by people of every
background that is not on you should
not be able to make
defamatory claims sweeping claims
about whole races of people and whole
societies
in this manner and at the moment
certainly in the weeks immediately after
that it was very very difficult to say
that
it's becoming easier but i wish it's a
classic example of
i wish we weren't stopped from having
that discussion and we're only stopped
from having it
because dishonest actors say if you add
any nuance to
to it then you are basically on the side
of the guy
who killed george floyd i think a big
part of this
is to do with the fact that we are not
built to
imbibe the entire world's news
instantly 24 7. yes there is too much
stimulus and too much information and
also in the past
in order to have got your message to
reach
10 000 people half a million people 10
million people
you would have had to have had jumped
through some hoops
that made sure you had integrity or
virtue or capacity
whatever it might be whereas now the
right tweet at the right time about the
right thing
that just sounds good can get a million
impressions within 24 hours we're not no
that's not the way that it's supposed to
be
this isn't this isn't a counter to free
speech your desire
to be able to say whatever you want does
not mean that i have to listen to it
this is what helen pluckrow said the
other day yeah um
and as a it might be a little outdated
now but i know that you're a massive fan
of sam harris's pullback from the brink
podcast which as far as i was concerned
was the best sense making us
wonderful and that ties back to what we
were saying about jk rowling
that if you have the capacity and the
platform and the
uncancelableness um that gives you
license to do this doing it is a good
idea
yeah but let me just add one other thing
it's not just
people in that position um
the hero of the hour to me is the young
woman
in the dc restaurant who wouldn't raise
her fist when the mob told her to
she isn't famous or she wasn't famous
she said almost certainly had no idea
that she was the person who would stand
against the crowd
she did
and everyone should want to be her
that's the goal that's the goal in this
era
is not to go along with the crowd you
see because the crowd says this terrible
thing has happened and as you say our
sense-making apparatus is all shot
and we don't have the time and like
okay i i could study all the footage of
the arrest of george floyd and then look
into the
arrest histories of the arresting
officers and his own
past and all of that i could do all that
or i could live my bloody life
but okay if we're forced to do all of
this sort of thing whenever there's an
explosion like this
at the very least there should be a
there should be a reward to people who
do not say
yeah of course i'll go along with
whatever it is you're telling me i've
got to go along with
that's why i say that the job in this
era of reasonable and decent people is
to not
join the crowd i'm very
by i mean it may just be i
don't have a great crowd love
in built particularly you and me both
right i'm not i'm i don't even
particularly like large sporting events
for that reason
been bliss for you this summer though oh
yeah no i no i mean i
i don't i wouldn't want to go with be
the only person in the stadium either
but
the point is i i just don't i don't like
very very large crowds because i know
what they can do and uh
i'm much happier uh as a
just i speak for myself i'm very happy
to hold my own opinion
and justify it to whoever wants to take
it on
but i do feel that the crowd
fear that some of us have is because we
know how swiftly it can stampede in a
wicked direction
and i do think that's happening i'm not
overstating it i do think it's happening
i think that the people who
are are allowing that roman legion like
thing to happen
who behind them have people saying we
want to destroy capitalism we want to
destroy the free market
we want to destroy the foundations of
civil order
you know property rights and i mean they
now say this thing is mainly
they say oh well these businesses are
insured so it doesn't matter how dare
you
how dare you when some family has saved
and worked like anything all their lives
to have some
a business that can provide for the
their children
and you decide that you can guess in
advance what their insurance policy is
so you have the right to burn the damn
thing down
they are trying to smuggle all those
things in at the moment
behind the first shield
and i say the job of the era is for
people to say
no to resist the crowd it doesn't matter
what it tells you to do
don't do it hold your own counsel don't
go along with it
if for no other reason than that we
cannot operate as a species
vulnerable to one person
acting appallingly somewhere else on the
planet at any one time
there's no way it's
a trojan horse delivery mechanism with a
bunch of
a bunch of very bad actors behind it
have you heard
of woke fishing
no i don't think i have you are going to
love this
the new york post uh sums it up as the
wokefish dating trend
shady men are pretending to be
progressive on
apps in an effort to bed progressive
girls
according to writer serena smith woke
fishermen are masquerading as
progressive in order to get laid
similar to the phenomenon of catfishing
where there is uh people post fake
dating profile photos
um and there's a quote here from reddit
of a
particular successful walk fisherman who
said
it worked i went to an anti-trump rally
started screaming [ __ ] trump and a bunch
of people joined in
i kept doing it all night until some
girl some cute girl entered our group
and then we hooked up later that night
uh he is um this is what i call
cuttlefishing of course
i think this is different i think that
this is doing it
from a much more trolly sort of
i think he's purposefully doing it to
say right this is just a tool that i can
use as opposed to someone who genuinely
believes it
i think the no no no no but i always
said the cuttlefish didn't believe it do
you not think
i think some of the guys are so
self-deceptive that they genuinely
believe that that's what they're doing
it's just their method of getting
themselves in that one of manner one of
my one of my favorite conversations that
i've had
regularly in the year since madness of
crowds came out was with
young heterosexual men who i described
the cuttlefish maneuver to
and they burst out laughing because that
was their strategy because
it's the laughter of self-recognition um
it's happened so many times in the last
year and
um i do think it's
cynical uh i think woke fishing is
obviously just an
extension of this i like the i like this
idea the woke fisherman
like with his gnarled hands
from his tiny beard and one of those
little hats on top
smoking a pipe at the woke c
um but well these people deserve each
other
um and of course it's all the
consequence
again of us not having the conversations
we should have been able to have
um if we if we had reasonable
conversations about men and women
and relations between the sexes instead
of allowing the craziest and most
deranged and unhappy people to dictate
all of the weather
then you wouldn't be able to have the
situation where
one person knowing they're being a liar
attracts another person who they have
contempt for
i mean which seems to me to be a
sub-optimal start to a relationship
perhaps um also if the difference
between you
sleeping with someone and not sleeping
with someone is whether or not they
shout [ __ ] trump
i think yes i think that there's
something amiss here
with you know the knobs and the the
dials need to be adjusted there's
there's a there's a more than a little
bit that's wrong with that
i don't think you should just restrict
yourself to one thing being wrong with
that
um there's an awful lot of oddities in
this by the way
but in general in recent years the sort
of the
politicization of dating is something
that's very very interesting
and what i'm always interested in that
is the way in which it's one directional
as far as i know on gay and straight
dating apps
you don't find people saying
no democrats
or um no no
pro-eu
it's only ever the other way around so
there's no running no brexiteers no
trumpies
there's a running joke in the dating
scene um any guy who puts
moderate on hinge is a republican and
the um sense here is that the overton
window of
optimal political um preference
on dating has been shifted so far left
that moderate is now
nazi yes yes now i can see the problem
there
um by the way uh uh the spectator we
published a very good column a couple
years ago by cosmo landsman
a wonderful journalist who's one of
those journalists who i particularly
love because he always writes columns
you think oh my god i can't believe that
somebody wrote that i'm allowed to be
published that's fantastic
he wrote a very funny column about why
sex with right wing women is a lot
better than
having sex with left-wing women and one
of my favorite details of this was that
during sex
with somebody who said worked at the
guardian
at some point during the encounter he um
used the phrase um you love it you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you and i might think that using the
term
you love it you [ __ ] to a guardian
employee
is treading in risky terrain anyhow it
struck cosmo as being the
mott zeus at the time and um he came out
with it
she immediately immediately apparently
immediately stopped
proceedings and made it clear that
uh something along the lines of just
because we're having sex
doesn't mean that you can degrade me as
a woman
and uh cosmo was sort of you know stuck
in a
tricky position here and i think said
something along the lines of
no no sure can i start again
though can i get back in and
uh and i don't know exactly how it
finished
maybe it didn't but anyhow the point is
is this he said he said this is a
nightmare this is the sort of thing that
happens with left-wing women
and right-wing women an awful lot more
fun in the sack
and this is provable and i'm i don't
think we have pie charts
graphs or something we can provide this
but i hear it
please i hear this story all the time
and i think i think it's um
it's uh it's definitely the case uh and
the gay scene uh
uh you you wouldn't want uh you wouldn't
want to
date an extinction rebellion protester
you you wouldn't want that you wouldn't
want to be
um you wouldn't want to be with somebody
who's
who you had to weigh i mean i'm not even
just talking about the sex i'm talking
about the fact that
you wouldn't want to be with somebody
who you were forever having to check
what you were saying with and who might
instead of
the normal thing most sort of normal
people it's not even a left right thing
if somebody says something that they
sort of don't agree with they said well
i don't agree with that and then you say
that's interesting why and then they
tell you
that's a normal human interaction that
is a relationship
you argue about the kids name oh i want
to call it alyssia no no i don't like
alyssia my aunt used to be called alyssa
she was a [ __ ]
yes exactly or or just you know things
like you know i've always had this
i've always thought this and and then
you know you is one of the nice things
about relationships you just
discover the other person discover the
oddity of the other person quite often
and
you know and that's all that's all good
you wouldn't want to be with somebody
nobody should want to be with somebody
who's policing all the time
around the boundaries to make sure that
you're exactly in lockstep with what
you're meant to believe
today it seems who would want that it
seems bizarre to me
especially that 69 is quite a popular
sex position it seems bizarre to me that
you can have
seen someone's [ __ ] inches from your
eyes
and not be allowed to call them a [ __ ]
it's like look
we have i agree it's outrageous
look the sex police need to steam in
and and have a have a discussion as i've
always said by the way i mean the
the hardest one on that one is is how
the rules are like that
and uh what's the name e.l james i don't
say pdj
50 shades of grey woman uh that sells by
the bucket load i mean that
i think i say that a man is a crowd
somewhere that's a very weird i mean
you know it's a very weird thing that
nobody bothered to have out
but at the same time as you know all
of the increasing policing about
relations between sexes were going on
women were buying hardcore s
m fiction porn by the truckload
i mean it definitely wasn't all men
buying that you know it sold it sold
like more copies
than the next four top selling of the
top five books
ever right in like combined instances
exactly and so and all of this is so
damn interesting
yes it's so interesting and
like nobody talks about it or can have
the conversation about it
we are right now subscribe below um are
you bored
of talking about social justice
in one way no because they're so
endlessly entertaining
uh the opposition you think they can't
come up with anything worse than madder
and then they do
and um you think i'm sure that must be a
satire
and it turns out not to be and uh
they make the same mistakes in the same
order every time
yeah i mean that stuff is endlessly you
know i mean
there are never by the way there's a
very serious ones i mean there was one
that came up the other day the american
psychological association decided to
become a sort of racist organization it
announced that all white people have the
uh uh have white supremacy a blood
a blood problem basically by being white
and now of course the american
psychological association last year
decided that men were a problem so i i
just don't think at some point the
american psychological association is
going to have to
refer itself to a psychologist i suppose
but
but but you know they do this on a very
regular basis the un did it today the un
uh declared that uh oh what was it yeah
until we address
oh you know the usual thing it says cis
heteronormativity patriarchy there won't
be peace in the world you think yeah i
don't know if that's going to solve
yemen
um but i mean you know it's actually
what you do if you can't solve yemen
isn't it
you start jabbering on about
heteronormativity somewhere in geneva
but but uh uh yeah they come up with
things every day
i'm fascinated by that but i also don't
spend all my time on it
or at least let me let me rephrase that
i spend
too much of my time on it but i always
balance it out with something worthwhile
right i literally think of it like
sustenance
if i spend some hours imbibing the
latest crazy [ __ ]
that everyone's doing today i read a
really good book
or i watch a terrific movie i've never
seen so
you're allowed to eat the hamburger as
long as you go and go to the gym at some
point
right i absolutely advise this for
everybody
like the joy of reading old books
the joy of watching old movies you know
just
take a classic movie you never bothered
with or a classic book
you've never read and read it it's the
best antidote to it and by the way it's
not just an antidote
it's very important because it reminds
you of how
people lived until the weird era we're
in
it helps give you very basic things that
our era is losing perspective
sense of judgment uh and much more so
that's
i i you know that that really is an
important tip if i can say so um people
cannot imbibe just
what we're being told to imbibe you said
on the trigonometry episode i watched
that was standing on the precipice
and it's interesting that you use that
word because i've been thinking about
this for quite a while toby ord who is
from the future of humanities institute
at oxford
um he wrote a book called the precipice
and it's all about existential threat
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yes yes yes i've
i've heard him yes wonderful australian
dude
uh also big into the um effective
altruism movement
fantastic yeah yeah yeah i read him on
altruism that's right huge
uh big picture thinking um and he called
his book the precipice
and he gives humanity's chances
of surviving the next century
one in three he gives humanity's chances
of reaching our full potential as a
civilization space faring colonize the
galaxy
at one in two so the vast majority of
our risk as a species
is front loaded within the next century
my concern is that smart people
like you like gad sad like
sam harris are using up brain power on
things that are self-defeating there's a
concept by robin hansen called the great
filter which explains the fermi paradox
why
are there not aliens out there he
suggests that there is a particular
section that we need to get past and
given that some of the smartest minds of
the last few years
have spent an inordinate amount of time
trying to work out whether men
are women or not to me feels like
that could be that if that's the reason
that as a species we don't reach our
full potential because
we decided to have these stupid tribal
like childish completely idiotic
self-defeating discussions yeah when the
asteroid comes
or a slightly more effective pathogen
hits or
pick your any one of the other
existential risks that toby brings up in
his book
like we did this to ourselves we we
built
it yeah yeah i couldn't anymore i've
said this quite often
in my own defense and if i'm not going
to do it who would
uh the purpose of for instance
manage the crowds is to give everyone
else a fast
track out uh i can't stress this enough
james lindsey and helen black rose as
you just mentioned that you've spoken
with
um also do an excellent task in a
portion of this to do with the academic
element in their new book um
cynical theories the point is is that
i don't want everyone to spend their
life reading unreadable books
i've read a significant number of them
in order to tell people not to read them
because it's not worth their time
and it's the same with quite a lot of
the subjects i deal with in a manner of
crowds is to say
this doesn't work don't fall for it
this is a ponzi scheme that's a fraud
now that is not because i want to spend
the rest of my life
talking about mad ponzi schemes invented
by frauds
it's because i want everyone else to get
through and all
round or across this or over the top of
this or burrow underneath it however
you're going to do it
as fast as possible it's very hard to do
it if you don't know what you're facing
because if you don't know what you're
facing you've got a disproportionate
likelihood of getting
killed blown up if you know what you're
facing
and you know the shortcut ways through
it's likely you can get on with the rest
of your life
and that's why i did them that's why i
wrote the madness of crowds first of all
and why
i've no now updated it is because i
wanted to stop particularly young people
first of all feeling intimidated by this
including
intellectually intimidated because they
shouldn't feel intellectually
intimidated by this
um secondly for them to realize them the
size of the thing that was that they're
being faced with in other words
a total reorganization of everything
which i submit is not going to work
but crucially that in in knowing and
understanding this you can get
through and get on with your life and
this is
this is a very important task because i
absolutely agree that for a lot of us
i mean millions and millions of us
everybody on the planet
we are wasting an opportunity at the
moment and the opportunity is as you
as you describe is that at this
time in our history there is so much we
can do
because we have access to knowledge in a
way that we never did in the past
our forbes had to
have to live with ignorance on a lot of
things a lot of things
and the most obvious one is if you
didn't have access to a book you didn't
know what was in it
who doesn't now have access to a book if
they've got a
relatively small sum of money um
they can join a lending library or they
can
buy a book online you can get a classic
book you can you can get hold of things
very recently our parents generation our
grandparents generation certainly that
wasn't the case
so that's not that's the case in area
after area we live in a time where
instead of being in ignorance about so
many things
you just you can just put it in into a
search engine
and why in that situation are we
spending our time as you say
talking about whether or not intersex
people
with a particular condition are the same
as trans people i mean i i often used to
joke you know this is what what'll
this is what happens when the barbarians
break in you know
we'll all get kalashnikov whilst talking
about gender neutral bathrooms
a horrible last thought to go through
your head
and and i've always thought that and and
as i say
a self-appointed task of mine is to try
to help other people get through that
itself but i stress and i think i said
this the other day to people on
trigonometry
there is also a very very important
thing that people need to bear in mind
which is not to put off what you're
meant to be doing with your life
not to put it off in particular
because you want the conditions of life
to become
optimal i i think i
have it here somewhere i i said to the
trigonometry people the other day i was
reading a
sermon that c.s lewis gave in 1939 just
at the outbreak of war
it's such a moving sermon because he
says in it um
you know these aren't optimal times but
they never were
they never were and as he says if human
beings
put off their search for beauty and
truth
and creation until the times were
optimal
they'd never have got started we would
never have started doing anything
and the thing that's so
desperate about the politicization of
everything
and the reason i say to people please
de-politicize your lives
is because it is not what you were meant
to do it's not what we were meant to do
to spend our time endlessly going around
such issues all of us every single
person watching
you and me all have an enormous amount
that we could do with our life an
enormous amount we can contribute
probably the least positive thing we can
contribute
is to some mass movement that's almost
certainly got enough members anyway
even if it was going in a good direction
and they almost never do
and what you're meant to be doing should
not be put off
until that movement gains total
ascendancy
firstly because it won't secondly
because it'll be hell even if it did
so don't put it off whatever it is
you're meant to be doing
but do work out how to survive in this
era
and then get on to doing the thing you
should be doing with your life because i
can assure every single person watching
it is going to be so much more damn
rewarding
than what you're being offered at the
moment
topics like that and that particular
passage that you pulled from the sermon
in 1939
that's what i want more of that's what i
want people like james lindsay with a
phd in
pure mathematics bro stop
just i don't want the world to have he
should be getting us to mars he should
be trying to do
that's what i want to hear i want to
hear more of that um
timeless evergreen wisdom you know that
is going to be the sort of thing that's
usable in 50 years time or 100 years
time
because i agree critical race theory
isn't i have two
quick questions before we go uh first
one who wins the u.s presidential
election this year
uh i don't think it's going to be clear
you're going to stick to both sides
don't agree i think that there's going
to be a lot of contested um
areas uh and i think that
it'll be hard for either side to concede
i think it's how
that's going to be the end of that um
final thing
what's your gym routine looked like in
2020 because
there was a period that i brought up
with dave rubin when he came on the show
um maybe sort of the last 18 months up
until the start of this year
where you went from normal douglas
murray
to jacked douglas murray
i want to know what i want to know what
you've been doing um
uh
talking about very much the
simple reason is i've stopped wearing
suits partly because i thought if it was
going to be the end of the world i
didn't have to put on a tie
and
um and um but i i've worked out all
well for quite a long time 15 years 20
years or so
uh for me it's it's um it's like the
most important point in the day when i
turn my mind off uh
i think it's very very good for people
for that people like me who basically
work all the time it would not work all
the time
think all the time you know when i'm not
writing i'm reading and
and you know and that's great but i
actually do need a time to turn off
and so for me the gym has always been
that
um and uh well i mean
i don't know if i can tell you my exact
routine though that means a chest is it
a push-pull leg split what are you in
five days a week
the people i know yeah normally four or
five days a week uh
three at the absolute worst lockdown was
tricky as it was for a lot of people
because however many of those banned
things you get they never quite
approximate
the weight um and um and i'm also
very anti-running in public
okay sorry i'm very very
it's not just i don't like to do it
myself i don't like seeing people coming
towards me on the pavement jibbering and
sweating
and dribbling
so so for me exercise has to be in the
gym
it has to be confined to that place i
think whatever you did
over the the 18 month period there was i
can't remember where the photo was
that went sort of semi semi sort of
viral online
i was weirdly i know exactly what you're
talking about because it was something
behind it's a lot there's a lot of
tricep in it and
it was it was a beard it was when i um
discovered what a thirst pick was which
was not something i'd ever
encountered before people said to me
you've posted a first pick and i said
what's that
and uh yes i know exactly what it was i
was in mexico and i happened to be
in the study that trotsky was
assassinated in which is not the obvious
place
if you lost the first trap picture you
were deliberately posting a first pick
you probably wouldn't choose an
assassination
site um anyhow
it was very kind of and flattering of
people
and um i'm deeply grateful and obviously
the next book
will be a davina mccall like workout
with douglas
i want a home dvd booty bums and toms
with douglas murray and comment below
comment below if you'd buy it and maybe
we'll get that
oh this is the final thing i lied to you
um you said if you hit the best seller
list that you might consider
reading the lyrics to whap is it
do we think that might happen i have
actually just heard the news from my
publishers
that we have made the best seller list
this week on its first week
um yes i um
this is the internet is listening i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be held to this
aren't i
yes it was it was it was a it was a
started as a dare with a friend
it was because as you as you probably
know i recited the works of en minaj
in um uh particularly her work on
anaconda
in uh the audible version of madness of
crowds and a lot of people
um particularly enjoyed that so i said
um if you enjoyed that then if this
becomes the best that i'll
do whap also because ben shapiro smashed
it
smashed it yeah um i i feel
a certain level of competition with ben
do you think he's kind of tried to take
your thunder a little bit there
i was worried about that i was worried
about that i thought it was quite a
strong play
and um
and so i do think if
if matters of crowds audible edition
which i strongly
recommend which is updated with the new
material and all that if that
um makes it into the best seller lists
again in audible
then i will do a rendition and unlike
ben i can promise now i will not say
the p word for the p word i will do the
whole thing
there we have it ladies and gentlemen a
link to the new updated paperback
version of the madness of crowds is
below if you've got an audible
subscription
i implore you for the good all that is
holy please use your credit for this
this month on the madness of crowds uh
douglas it's
so good i can't wait to get you back man
it's uh i always love talking to you
a great pleasure well likewise see you
soon i open take care
[Music]